the European Union has implemented
identification rules based on certain
fundamental principles and a
traceability system for all farm animals
if we take the bovine species for
example Chuck here just after birth will
receive a unique identification number
which is printed on his two ear tags
this number also appears on Chuck's
individual Passport
along with information that is specific
to him each individual animal like Chuck
also appear on a holding registration
that records information about their
birth and travels the European
Commission requires that any movement of
cattle either traveling within their
country of residence or to other Member
States is to be registered in a national
database take Anna for example she was
born in Holland was then moved to be
raised in France before she was moved
again here to Spain where she's about to
meet Chuck so when Chuck and Anna do
travel to their rendezvous their
movements will be constantly monitored
and checked by traces online along with
the thousands of other individual
animals traveling throughout the
European Union every day all data in
bovine passports is managed by beau vex
a system that facilitates an exchange of
information between the national
databases a system that will digitize
all paper passports in the near future
beau vex and Tracy's provide information
about where animals travel which animals
were together where they stayed and
where they're now located the Tracy's
system will be essential in providing a
fast exchange of information in the
event of a potential outbreak of a
contagious disease because it will
enable national authorities to react
quickly based on the same information so
individual animals can be traced back to
their point of departure or traced
forward to their final destination to
support traces the animal disease
notification system a dns is permanently
operational and ready to provide early
warnings via
to notifications about important animal
diseases traces provides a comprehensive
system of traceability that provides
protection and security for both
consumers and animals such as Anna and
Chuck traces protecting animals
facilitating trade